irgendwann
ist einfach der kleinste kapitel die
nicht hier gesehen habe sind die
wichtigen dinge die ich in meinen blogs
tage
bekommen in der messen bruder
springsteen
er werde ich nie verstehen warum so ein
motorradfahrer sich denken borsten
geiler sound darum bin ich auf keinem
bild drauf
niveau ziemlich
besorgt auf meinem völlig besoffen auch
mal nach dem puls war der hessisches
gesicht wenn ich bei drei angekommen ok
13 erst waren die macht jetzt auch noch
mal eine kurze lücke von ihrer mutter
und weiß was ich finde es schön ist
diese toilette
gut geschossen
dieses multimedia fans mal wieder sagen
ja du bist auch schön eklig die habe ich
extra schön
es ist meine wäsche
[Musik]
wenn ich wollte mir schon längst warm
sein allerdings hat seinen reiz hat
angerufen dass wir mal auf ihrer
terrasse nach ihrem wäscheständer
schauen sollen jetzt sehen ja nicht so
ganz einstimmen deutschland gehabt um
die trauben in ihre wäsche draußen
kannst du dir nächste mal noch so eine
warnweste anziehen
wie teuer war wie
gemacht für mich ganz kurze erklärung
sandra ist gerade in ischgl den ist
ischgl österreich oder schweiz
perfekt aber auch einfach auf dem
ständig die ganze zeit raus diese schuhe
nicht mehr so schade also denkt dass die
lustig ist ich
denke mal wir haben nichts gesehen doch
das schönste terrassen design was ich
hier gesehen habe ein gurkenglas wo
kippten drin sind irgendwelche
vergammelten schuhe kartons
wäscheständer und alle möglichen
schrauben und feuerzeuge die die
eigentlich aus braucht
nach soll auch noch ein schirm von inge
heinz markert er hat dich vorstellte
[Musik]
zugleich macht uns karten von dem auto
denn das auto war richtig teuer ist der
da capo und anderes nämlich eben
[Musik]
das auto kaputt gemacht hat ist auch das
anders ich könnte jetzt verhandelt was
ist die frage
ich hatte jetzt nicht was ich vergessen
sogar
zwei tage das
war nicht extra falls irgendjemand
fragen habt das im lotto gewonnen
wie oft kann man ihnen schulterblick
waren
niedrig was machst du
denn jetzt gefahrenbremsung
wir versuchen jetzt auf jeden fall hier
leben anzukommen umwelt
[Musik]
freue mich dass wir heute wandern gehen
ich habe auch ordentlich was eingepackt
ich kann euch das mal zeigen
also ich habe hier einmal ein bierchen
dabei aber natürlich 0,0 weil damit die
historische ist zum wandern dann habe
ich auch noch bis ins netz mitgenommen
so ein bisschen nüsse und so habe ich
extra eingepackt und dann haben wir uns
auch noch eine stunde geschmiert falls
sie nachher hunger haben
vor weihnachten patschinski mit ihren
freunden was
hast du 30
[Musik]
bringt ein bisschen sekt
das da vorne ist diese burg zu der wir
wollten
dass die aussieht
wiener haarspitze
und wenn ein lied meine lippen verlässt
ich checke halt auch dass jemand der
halt nach rechts und links in der mitte
ist ein plus größer als eins a und x9 ja
klar müssen wir hier lang in der burg
lebt rapunzel und besucher nicht
rapunzel
wir wandern hier eine stunde hoch da
hinten ist eine bahnstation in der
straße direkt vor der burg
also dass noch zwei mal war es drastisch
aus
so jetzt ist der faden gerissen
der herbst kommt ich habe die kiste
gegriffen
an der stelle auch noch mal übertrieben
vetschau dort anstelle die meinte dass
wir extra den weg nach oben laufen
müssen wir das beste schnitzel gibt was
haben die oben nur brezeln man geht echt
nicht einfach einen baum bier half mit
bei der rettung er ist da kannst du foto
von mir und dem kaiser machen
das ist apfelschorle nicht dass das
video irgendwie
was das alter
wir sind wieder zu hause angekommen vom
spaziergang und
es halt einfach wandern dicker wir sind
da vier stunden rumgelaufen es ist
stockfinster draußen 20 egal ob in slim
ich wollte eigentlich fühlen als wir
gerade im gym waren allerdings habe ich
es vergessen also vertraut uns einfach
dass wir trainieren waren schon montag
weiter und herren nicht guten tag ist es
nachts und da wirklich vorbei